Elon Musk has now visited the Border
exactly as many times as Kamala Harris
and Joe Biden which is one I think
that's true I don't know I saw it on
Twitter so fact check that one but Elon
Musk is currently down at the border and
he just did two live streams from Eagle
Pass in Texas showing illegal
immigration and he he says he backs a
border wall so Elon Musk is coming out
saying build the wall going out of the
Border I think it's really interesting
as to why he chose to do it first and
foremost it's a big story I do think he
is testing the capabilities of live
streaming on X formerly Twitter and so
this is a big deal for him to go out and
provide coverage of this will generate a
ton of attention very very good for the
platform so we'll definitely talk about
all that oh boy